SPEAKER: Still not working.
Yeah, we had some issues
with the clickers.
Now it's fixed.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Thank you very much,
guys, for turning up.
Just a small disclaimer
about this session.
It's about gaming.
I know in your pamphlets,
it says for general markets.
So this is for gaming.
You can stay if you want
to if you're not a gamer,
but just to keep your
expectations right,
just the translation went
off from English to Chinese.
So just to set the
expectations right for there.
OK.
[SPEAKING CHINESE] And that's
my only Chinese that I know.
So I'm not going to keep
this session in Chinese.
So please put those
earpieces in and listen
in to the translation, please.
Thank you.
So today we're going to
talk about in this session
about the 2017 global markets,
where the opportunity is
in terms of gaming, and where
you should export in 2017.
And in this session, we're
going to talk specifically more
about the Middle East
and North Africa.
It's not the only growth
region, but it's the one
that actually grows the most.
So we're going to do a slight
deep dive into that region
and how you can localize and
be successful in the region.
So we're going to talk
about three things today.
First, the global
markets, as I said.
We'll do the slight deep
dive into Middle East
and how you localize in that
region, as well as how to win
and how to go for
it in that region.
So let's identify the
key markets in 2017
and look at the global
map in that first stage.
So if we look at revenue--
sorry, let's ask ourselves
first a question.
If you're not
exporting out, I'll
give you a reason why to do it.
Google Play did a great
research the other year
about the growth
of installs that
comes from global apps,
which is app companies that
have penetration in more than
five markets versus single app
markets.
And the ones that are
global have 2.4 times more
in-style growth than the markets
with apps with single market
installs.
So it's a great incentive
to actually go abroad
because you can
find your audience.
You can find audience also
that are more valuable to you
than in your home markets.
All right.
So if we look at the
three stages of exporting
your app in the first place--
not just your game, but the
app in the first place--
so first, we identify
the opportunity.
So how do we do that?
First, we need to identify
our KPIs in the first place.
What does matter in the
market that I'm going into?
And which stage of me
launching the app am I into?
Is it installs that I'm
actually focusing on?
Or is it LTV, or
return on investment?
What is it?
Identify those key metrics.
And then look into data.
And there is plenty
of third party data,
including Google, that can help
you identify those markets.
The second part is actually
localizing the app itself.
We're going to go through
a couple of stages.
Earlier we had the
GO-Global with Google Play,
explaining how you
can localize the app.
But also Google can help
to localize the ads, which
is the front face.
Often most the first interaction
that a potential gamer
or an installer would have
with you is through your ads.
A good way to identify markets
is looking at your own data.
Sometimes that could
give a great indication
of where the data is.
So this is a snapshot from
our test account at Firebase
looking at where the data
is coming from in terms
of country and region first--
so the US in this instance
gives it a lot of traffic--
but also the smaller markets
like in Europe or the UK,
as well as in Asia,
but also looking
at different demographics and
other sub-segments of your data
that gives you more
indication of where to head.
So let's look at
the revenue that
are coming in through mobile
gaming in the first place.
So this is Newzoo data.
This is not ours.
So this has unified,
both iOS and Android.
So we look at the
most of the money that
comes in through mobile
gaming is actually from APAC.
No surprises there.
About 45% of the global
revenue is actually
coming in from APAC.
And a distant second is
from the North America,
with Western Europe and Latin
America following slow after.
Middle East is
still on a low par
in comparison to
the other region,
but it actually grows the most.
So 26.6% is estimated growth
between 2015 and 2016.
And Latin America
is also showing
quite interesting
growth in that aspect,
especially countries
like Mexico, Argentina,
but also the smaller
South American markets
like Uruguay, Peru.
But we're going to take a
closer look, as we said,
at the Middle East region,
as well as the North African
region for 2017.
So there's three reasons--
I like to talk about
things in threes,
so you're going to notice that
in the coming presentation now.
So the first one is scale.
You can find markets in the
Middle East and North African
region that provides
you with a great scale.
Countries like Morocco,
Egypt, have a lot of people.
Although maybe not the
highest return of investment,
but there's a lot of installs
coming in from there.
And you can also find markets
with high lifetime value giving
great returns,
especially for games.
Countries like UAE, or
Israel, or Saudi Arabia
has a great amount of volume
of people with deep pockets
putting into games.
The third reason also,
which is quite rare wherever
you go, especially here
in APAC, is actually
low competition in the region.
The competition can best
be described as fragmented.
And there is quite a small
scene of really large players,
local players, that are
still in the region,
and most of those players are
from Israel or from the UAE.
In the other markets,
they're quite small
and haven't really penetrated
the market successfully.
So there's a big opening
for you guys as developers,
as gaming developers,
to actually enter
the region because
the competition is
quite low and fragmented.
So what are the growth
drivers that drives
that growth in the Middle East?
Right now, we see a huge upswing
in carrier building, which
is very important for
developing nations
in the region, especially
when we have partnered up
with carriers in Egypt
and Saudi Arabia,
where the credit card
penetration is actually
quite low.
So now we can successfully
drive those revenue bits
from gamers in that region.
But also, the mobile
penetration is on the up,
and it's growing
a lot, especially
coming in from
Egypt, if you look
at that as a country with
more than 60 million people.
And people are actually
going mobile only, not just
mobile first, but mobile only.
So the mobile penetration
is increasing a lot,
and people are using it
for a variety of tasks.
But also in terms of
barriers to entry,
there's low financial and
technical barrier to entry
there, especially
carrier billing
has solved the financial
issues over there as well.
So let's look at
the top markets,
first in terms of volume.
So Saudi Arabia is largest
market in terms of volume.
This is Google.com Queries.
Not necessary
installs, but in terms
of interest on
Google.com, Saudi Arabia
shows its muscles with a lot of
queries in the gaming sector.
And this is between Q1, Q3, '16.
So this is not the full year.
The picture might change
at the end of the year,
but nonetheless, Saudi Arabia,
Egypt, as well as Israel,
Morocco, UAE following after.
What is most interesting is
that Egypt is growing the most,
as we noticed before.
It's a country
with a high volume,
but it is also growing the most.
Saudi Arabia is also showing a
lot of potential in the region.
And one note to make is
actually that Morocco
is on the slight decline.
There's no real explanation why.
It's just generally,
the gaming interest
has gone down
slightly year on year.
No, we should do this.
Here we go.
So which type of games
are the most interesting?
And what are the type of
games that people in MENA
are playing?
So massive multiplayer online
games are very, very popular,
as well as casual games.
And I would say casual
games is more tailored
towards the female segment.
So if we take in this
example Saudi Arabia,
the casual games
in that region is
very driven by the
female demographic.
But also, I know there's a big
scene for role-playing games
here in China.
There's quite an interest
overall also in role-playing
games, and that's
also the sector
that is growing the most.
So I would like to
look first at the cost
and then look at the
return investment
to see how attractive the
market is in terms of entry.
In terms of CPI, this is
CPF and Google Play only.
We don't have the iOS store.
We can't really share that.
But if we look at
the Google Play
CPI, and we share a range--
I don't want to give
you a specific number
because we can't really do that.
But in terms of a range between
a low range and a high range,
Saudi Arabia ranks
the highest right now.
We've seen a sudden
influx, especially
during Q3 of a few Israeli game
players who've gone in there
and jacked up the CPI slightly.
UAE, Israel is coming.
They're in the mid-range.
And Egypt and Morocco are
the cheapest countries
to target in terms
of cost per install.
There we go.
All right.
We've seen that those countries
have high costs, like Saudi,
like UAE, and Israel.
But also they have
quite a high return.
This is the lifetime value.
So over the last 90 days,
how many installs are driven
in the country,
but also how much
revenue in terms of in-app
purchases are driven?
Then we divide it
between each other
and create an index over it.
So UAE is driving
the most amount
of in-app purchases per install,
followed by Israel and Saudi
Arabia.
Also no surprises there.
Because of the low income
barrier in Morocco and Egypt,
we end up in a slightly
lower tier over there.
So this is a suggested
model for you to look at.
If you want to tier
markets up and see, OK,
which is the most interesting
market for me to enter in,
rather than looking
[INAUDIBLE], should
I go to a high LTV
market or low CPI market,
mix them up and tier them up.
That's the smart thing to do.
So in this case, countries
in the tier one segment,
which is the blue piece, has
a high LTV, but a low CPI,
so the best of two worlds,
or a relatively high LTV
and low CPI.
And following down to the
segments of two and three,
where you have high
LTV and a high CPI,
a low LTV and a low CPI, but
also basically the gray basket
here is countries
or markets maybe
to avoid or maybe look at an
alternative way of targeting
them.
So in this instance, taking
the top five markets,
Israel is the only country
to end up in the tier one.
As we saw earlier, Israel
provided with moderate CPIs,
but also quite good returns.
So it's a good market
to actually target
because it provides
the best of two worlds.
Saudi ends up somewhere
in the middle,
but ends up slightly
on the high CPI stage.
It had the high CPI,
but also provided
actually quite good
returns, together with UAE.
So yeah, Egypt and
Morocco ends up
on a slight downturn
on low CPI as well as
low returns on investment.
For the markets that
have low returns,
like Egypt and Morocco,
it can be [AUDIO OUT],
but you can also,
through AdWords,
also target high-end
Android devices,
like Samsung S7 Edge or those
really expensive devices.
They tend to also
have similar returns.
How do we localize in the
Middle East and North Africa?
So there's a couple
of things to consider.
So first of all, why should you
localize in the first instance?
First of all, is
discoverability.
People will find your
app much easier--
that's the most obvious reason.
Having just localized
keywords, for instance, so
localized string in
the app description,
it just helps people to
find the app much easier.
But also, local app team
stores like in Google Play,
they're looking for apps
that have a good rating,
but also a localized
feeling that they
want to feature on their page.
So just translating
the front end
in terms of the Play
Store text just makes
you more discoverable and more
favorable in the Play Store
team's eyes.
The second thing is
about the engagement.
About 72% of users we've
been interviewing in the past
prefer a localized app,
especially in the Middle East,
as well as we've seen
an upturn in terms
of both engagement and
returns on investment
for apps that have localized.
And the third bit is
about the experience.
Brands tend to also strengthen
their experience with the users
by localizing in
the local language.
It just looks so much better
when you have, for instance,
a game coming into China.
You don't want to
have it in English.
You want to have it
in Chinese, and you
want to have it fully in
Chinese, both culturally
and on the translation piece.
And in terms of if we
look at the Middle East
in terms of regions, there is a
lot of subregions in the Middle
East.
There's not just one big region.
And it's the easiest
way to look at it.
It's in three subregions.
The first one is the
GCC, which is the Gulf
Coast, as we call it.
It's around Kuwait,
Bahrain, UAE, Oman, and also
Saudi Arabia.
They encompass this
high-income region and very
oil-rich nations that
are quite culturally
similar to each
other, and they're
quite easy to
target in one bunch.
But there is also
differences, obviously,
between the
countries, but they're
quite similar in terms
of localization in terms
of culture and also language.
The second region
we're talking about
is the Levant, which is Iraq,
Jordan, Lebanon, as well
as Syria.
Those markets are also
quite similar to each other
in many different ways.
Right now, politically,
they're very
similar to each other, but
also in terms of language
and how they speak.
More specific, Syria
and Lebanon are
quite similar to each
other, as well as Jordan.
With Iraq, it would be a
slightly different type
of language used.
And the third one would be
the Maghreb region, which
is the North African region.
Talking about the language
itself, it's quite similar.
You can use the same type of
expressions and idioms used
in that language in that region
with the exception of Egypt.
That's its own
slight small region
because the language
is just so different
as well as the culture.
There we go.
So there's also a
difference, as I said before,
in terms of language
preference, just looking at it.
Although I strongly
recommend to localize fully
in Arabic, more than 50%,
more than 5 out of 10 users
would prefer to have a
localized map in Arabic.
And it's one of the most widely
spoken languages in the world.
However, if you want to enter
easily with an English speaking
app and don't have the means
to translate or localize,
UAE probably would be the
easiest market to enter
because it's--
take an example
like Dubai, which
is one of the Emirates in
the United Emirates region.
90% of them are ex-pats
who speak English,
so there will be less of a
problem going into that region.
But the other countries do
localize not just the language,
but also the culture is
super important, especially,
we're going to look at
it a little bit later,
for Saudi Arabia.
And there's a couple of things
to consider when you translate.
So, for instance, having
the right translations
in the right variety
of different languages
in the region is important.
For instance, if we look at
the third bit over there,
when you translate directly from
a foreign language into Arabic,
the language can
look very weird,
like it does here right now.
It might not see it from the
front, but this is actually--
we tend to put the
characters together,
so it forms into a word.
So here, they're all
disconnected from each other,
but the right way
to do it in Arabic
is actually write it
together like this
and connect the words together.
So that's something to do.
And the main point here is
hiring a local translator
to do all of these
things, and not
just machine translate
the whole into Arabic.
It can be very, very
wrong and actually
have a negative impact
on the user experience.
But also, the UI is important
to localize because most
of the UIs in Arabic, it's
not from left to right,
it's actually from
right to left.
The language is
written differently.
So if you have menus
and all of these things,
it's important to
localize the whole look
and feel of it
into right to left.
And we have a couple
of examples here
of companies that
have done very well.
For instance, the
Castle Clash was
IGG.com has done it
very well in terms
of just looking at your
app store localization,
completely in Arabic.
But also the screenshots,
if you look at it here,
they're completely in Arabic.
But also the icons
and the characters
have been modified
to the local culture.
This is an example
from Saudi Arabia.
So the female character
here has a small veil.
I don't know how
you feel about that,
but in terms of
how they actually
spoke to the local
population, they
added that because local
women cover up their faces.
So that's what they did
with the local icon as well.
There we go.
And they saw a great uplift.
So the whole localization effort
they took from there actually
saw a great uplift.
In terms of active
installs in the region,
they saw a 48% uplift,
and the revenue
took a 58% uplift
just four months
after they localized the game.
So another company
that did it quite well
was ZeptoLab, who grew
quite nicely in the Middle
East in the last year or so.
So they localized
also the same thing.
They took the screenshots
and the whole description
as well as the in-game.
And the actives and
installs on Google Play
rose by more than 74% over
the four-month period.
So can someone-- it's
something that really viral
on the internet
a couple of years
ago is this painting from the
Spanish painter who forgot
this painting inside a church.
And this old lady three
years ago took this painting
and tried to repair it because
it was slightly damaged.
This is a painting of Jesus.
So she tried to repair it.
And it started looking
more like this.
So what are we
trying to say here?
You need to be more
on the native check.
You have to localize correctly.
It has to look
like the original.
So if you look at local
games and how they succeed,
they look like they are local.
So don't be that painting over
there and try to copy/paste.
So do it more on the
native side and be
very local in your approach.
And also avoid stereotypes.
In the Arab region, there's a
lot of controversies in media,
and there's a lot of things
in tension politically and all
these things.
As well as in movies and
other culture aspects,
they tend to have a
negative Arab stereotype.
So avoid those things when
releasing new games, as well
as in the in-app characters.
Don't have that
negative stereotype.
This is a couple of examples
from American movies, where
they portrayed Arabs
quite negatively
and had an actually quite severe
impact on the movies being
popular in the Middle
East in the first place.
And also another
thing to consider
is that the Middle East
region is [? rife. ?]
It has a lot of
different seasonalities.
We Celebrate a lot
of different things.
More specifically, like
[? Eid ?] [? al-Adha, ?] which
is the pilgrimage to Mecca that
Muslims take to Saudi Arabia.
And that's something that
is happening every year.
But another thing that is more
specific for gaming that's
really important is Ramadan.
It's a four-week period.
It's a month somewhere
in June, July nowadays.
It goes back 10 days every year.
People tend to have an uprise
in terms of games, installs,
as well as revenue
spent during that time.
So it's quite important to
be in those seasonalities
to boost your installs
and boost your revenues.
But also another thing,
in the Gulf Coast region,
August is so hot that
people stay inside.
And we see a slight rise in
terms of gaming activities
during that time.
So as we see here, as
I said about Ramadan,
people tend to spend
more time inside.
Because I don't know if you know
Ramadan, it's a fasting period.
So people don't eat, and
they tend to stay inside.
Don't go to work either.
And that phenomenon is more
known in the Gulf Coast region
where people can afford to
stay at home and not work.
So the gaming revenue tends
to go up for all ages.
This is four weeks
prior to Ramadan.
It just goes up during the
four weeks and during Ramadan.
It just goes up in terms of
revenues spent in the games.
And the region is
crazy about YouTube.
If there's one way I would
tell you to reach users
in that region, it's YouTube.
The watch time is off the hook.
If you look at,
for instance, like
Kuwait, which is the
neighboring country of Iraq,
had twice the watch
time of users in the US,
who are already quite
savvy YouTube users.
But look at UAE, Qatar,
Bahrain, Saudi Arabia--
they're all much
more than the US,
and they're very engaged users,
and entertainment is just
a big subject in terms of
entertainment consumes.
And that's something to keep in
mind when targeting the region,
is that YouTube is probably the
one best way to actually enter
the region, is create
content for YouTube.
So as I said before, the
region is quite diverse,
and it's very different.
One way to look
at it is how much
they've adopted some of
the religious aspects
of the region.
So Saudi Arabia, if we
look at one end, which is
they tend to be
more conservative.
And that's something
to consider when
you target the country
through different creatives,
but also the in-game
aspect of it.
So for instance,
female characters
should not be showing
too much skin,
and also avoid those regional
issues in that aspect,
and don't offend the
religion in any way.
Just have a closer
look of exactly what
that means for you guys.
But on the other end,
you have countries
who are a little bit
more liberal, where
those things are not an issue.
But countries like
Lebanon and Israel
tend to be quite rife
with political issues.
Those are the things that
you should avoid, especially
in Israel with the
Israel-Palestine conflict.
So that's something to
just really, really avoid.
But as I said, the
region is very diverse,
and it's different--
like, targeting
has a different
implication wherever
you go in those countries.
So in terms of localization,
you can do it in a smart way.
You don't have to go
fully local and native.
We can make it easy
and just divide them
by three in a bunch.
So first of all, it's just like
unlocking that new opportunity,
testing the market.
It can localize some of the
aspects of the Play Store
items, maybe have the
screenshots of the promotion,
use the automatic translation
that Google Play provides,
but also maybe doing APK
translation as well as
the screenshot of the promotions
maybe can be localized as well.
The next step is just to ramp
up the advancement in terms
of localization, is letting
know that you actually
care about the users.
So that can be going
a little bit further
by translating the app string,
for instance, or localizing
the app screenshots,
not just the promotions.
But the absolute best
way is to actually
absolutely go local and team up
and partner up with local teams
to help you translate the whole
game, as well as co-partner
with marketing agencies to
actually get that local look
and feel.
So that's the three different
ways where you can do it.
But as we said
before, you can beta
test the market by having
limited localization
in that effort.
You can just start looking
at the first bucket
of localization.
There we go.
So what are the key
takeaways in this segment?
The global markets
are all increasing
in terms of the opportunity
for gaming, for instance.
But the Middle East is
showing the most progression
in terms of growth.
And that's the key
region I want to tell you
about you guys today.
It's a great opportunity
with low barriers, especially
countries like Saudi Arabia
and Israel showing the best
returns, as well as the
trade-off between cost
and returns.
Multiplayer games, as well as
casual games, are very popular.
And another thing,
also, the third thing,
when we talk about localization,
is having that native check.
The localization feel
is extremely important
when you go to that region.
But also, having
the right targeting
in terms of seasonality
like Ramadan
is very important for
increasing that gaming
revenue during that
period, as well
as August in certain
regions of the Middle East.
So I think that's it for me.
If there is any questions?
Maybe not immediately, we
can take it afterwards.
I'm here for about
30 minutes more.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] I have
a question about [INAUDIBLE]
because the question is
if the app [INAUDIBLE],
is it allowed to
publish in Google Play?
Because according
to my knowledge,
it's not allowed in [? Latin ?]
[? America. ?] [INAUDIBLE]
if it's OK in the
[? MENA. ?] I mean,
if the game [INAUDIBLE]
with carrier billing.
Carrier billing is one of the
most important [INAUDIBLE]
in Middle East.
SPEAKER: It's an up and coming--
I'm not aware of any legal
issues or policy issues
that we have.
But we've recently
teamed up, for instance,
with the Saudi Telecom
players to have
carrier billing integrated
into our platform as well.
I'm not aware of any
policy issues in any ways.
But maybe we can double
check that for you
and maybe send out a
clearer answer for you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: It's a great speech.
I learned a lot.
SPEAKER: Thanks.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And quick question.
You mentioned that Arabic is
the language that covers MENA.
But there are also
a lot of difference,
you mentioned like GCC,
and also the Maghreb area.
What's the language difference
between those areas?
Or can we just localize the
game for Arabic and just
for one region, and it will
work automatically for the rest?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
It's more of the expressions
used in the language.
So the written Arabic is
very similar wherever you go.
It's the spoken Arabic
that is different.
So certain dialects
can be so different
that people don't
understand each other.
And also, the
expressions used are
different from
different regions.
So in terms of, if you
want to go safe, as I said,
you have those three main
regions that I pointed out.
They are quite similar in terms
of even lingual similarities
between each other.
AUDIENCE: So pretty much spoken
language is much different,
but written language
is [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: The written
language is pretty uniform.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you very much, guys.
And I hope you enjoy
the rest of the day.
[APPLAUSE]